l'éclat économique du spécialiste des
bijoux est il en train de se ternir
hier mathy annonçait la fermeture de
huit points de vente en france 8 sur 37
mais c'est surtout l'annoncé de la
suppression de 54 postes qui a marqué
les esprits
la direction ne s'exprime pas pas plus
que les syndicats maison matinée
pourtant pas une entreprise comme les
autres dans le paysage franc comtois si
vous parlez de matty les gens arrivent à
situer besançon c'est incroyable à
l'inversé
donc oui c'est c'est un drame humain 54
licenciements il ya à peu près un peu
plus d'une année on avait déjà entendu
parler de grosses difficultés amati
alors est ce que le plus vite c'est le
prétexte pour pour m comment dire au
chômage 54 personnes peut-être également
l'horlogerie n'est pas le seul secteur
en souffrance l'aéronautique et ses
sous-traitants sont en chute libre des
pme qui représentent 15% de l'activité
industrielle dans notre région bourgogne
franche comté
un secteur qui dit c'est pourtant les
coups de mou de l'automobile dans cette
entreprise les salariés chôment deux
jours par semaine
la plupart des commandes sont annulées
la situation moyenne est à -40%
et en fait vous avez des gens qui sont
beaucoup plus impactés notamment ceux
qui étaient dans les problématiques
liées à boeing qui sont sûres du moins
60 - 70 % enfin iliad et des cas
extrêmement grave et c'est aujourd'hui
fins et dans les mois qui vont dire
qu'on va voir sans doute des sociétés en
très grande fragilité
le secteur ne redécollera pas tant que
les frontières resteront fermés à quand
la reprise personne ne le sait en
attendant il faut garder le savoir faire
il faut tenir il faut résister je sais
pas quel est le mot mais en tout cas
tenir parce que ces compétences sont
importantes pour les entreprises avouent
un outil heures un régleur enfin vous
vous saurez pas des gens comme ça en peu
de temps
cet autre sous traitant lui ne pourra
pas attendre il va se séparer d'une
vingtaine d'employés sur 120
l'aéronautique dans notre région fait
travailler un peu plus de 3000 salariés